[Music]
guys welcome to the podcast
thanks here we are
been looking forward to this it's the
first face-to-face podcast i've done in
a while
so um i'm looking forward to it and i
guess where where i wanted to start is
let's sort of dig right into
this psych story so i guess let me come
to you first like from your perspective
you can speak on behalf of the other
guys as well but like what what gave you
the confidence to take that leap in
starting soap or being involved in this
business journey i'm actually going to
pass the baton on
right at the very beginning yeah i think
simon can articulate this quite well
okay cool yeah i think um i think it's
important to note that
when i think olly was the one that came
with the idea and said guys we've been
successful doing what we're doing for
such a long time we've got our own
clients we've got a very clear way of
doing things but actually we were quite
reluctant to go and do our own thing and
the reason for that is because we were
doing well we were in a really good
rhythm we had each other we had you know
we were established but
i think the reluctance was we don't want
to go and just get into the back of the
queue and just do what everyone else is
doing yeah and so there's a bit of a
back and forth saying well we don't want
to do that and so we said well
why should we do that why should we get
to the back of the if we're going to do
it let's do it differently let's really
take the time to go and think about you
know what
where is the industry going and part of
that was we actually went internally for
a while as well to really do some talent
acquisition work
and this enabled us to get a very
different perspective of
the industry really understand the
challenges how decisions are made
internally and so when we came to
creating soap tower acquisition as a
service was created because we
understood
that a lot of our clients were looking
at building capability in-house and
recruitment conventionally goes against
the interests of our clients so these
were the types of things that we were
really trying to kind of really
understand early early on and that's the
reason why we thought okay let's just go
and and solve this so as you said a lot
of people will start a recruitment
business and know you'll hear them with
it differently and blah blah but that
that's what you really thought about
which then that okay let's let's really
give this a go and try as you said which
is where task came from very old and i
guess just quickly on that and feel free
to any of your answers what what do you
think is the if did you all go internal
for a bit or not
so yeah me me and simon did okay
no i stayed on an agency for a little
bit longer yeah so i guess for youtube
then what do you think is like the most
common misconception of
like a being a town acquisition person
that agencies make you think
recruitment
yeah
hands down i think that there's this
stigma attached to oh if you're internal
then
you're not very good at recruitment and
i have to say now
not only are they paying big money
they're attracting big talent but
actually there's so much complexity
within an organization internally that i
don't think you actually really
understand it until you've experienced
that yeah and so what you what you tend
to find is that
you know
from an agency perspective you're quite
blinkered you're quite selfish with oh
that that job's been pulled
or
i was told it's exclusive and now all of
a sudden something's changed or the job
description has changed when you work
internally you understand how those
decisions are made you understand how
you know what they're thinking and when
they're going to market so the
communication is very different and
having that experience firsthand
means that we can address those
challenges from that perspective
proactively so even as an agency having
that knowledge gives us the ability to
really understand the internal makeup of
our clients and appreciating that
sometimes
there are going to be things that are
going to change and we can be proactive
to ask the right questions to understand
exactly where we stand so it's all about
qualifying where you stand within that
sense well um just curious yeah worth
did you deal with agencies when you was
in time acquisition wow like did you
have any have you got any like i've i've
had a few people that went internal yeah
there's always normally locker i don't
know a pet peeve or a storyboard like i
just can't believe these agencies
actually tried to do it because you see
on the other side that might be you
might told an agency 10 times look we
just don't look at cvs that you spec in
so this is the way you do it i don't
know i'll send you another fight i don't
know it was there anything that you saw
that comes to mind not really not that
comes to mind i think there was um
see i was quite open to spec cvs okay
but the problem for me was you spec a cv
in and not follow up with a call and
actually sell me the candidate it's
you've only done half the job and yeah i
think that
presenting a cv and i think there's a
lot of people that will just spec a cv
in um but without following up on the
call and actually selling that candidate
in it's it's worthless really um there's
a couple of candidates i received um
and
yeah on paper they were they were
shocking uh it was only them for a
reference that i actually then ended up
going back to an agency to say i'd
actually like to speak to your candidate
and should that person have actually you
know
done and referenced that candidate it
probably would come at a different
different conclusion so how how how
would we describe
the first year so just so obviously i
said where the business is about today
like what did the business look like in
the first year just quickly like where
did you finish the first year was it
just still does you free is there a
couple of people involved straight away
so actually started as a fight it was
kind of a staggered entry but um so it
was
ali ben
patrick myself
um and then there's there was another
who was with us at the time as well so
there was there was there was a few of
us at the beginning we were actually six
when we were actually six yeah so yeah
we obviously had a few connections in
the market who um
were lucky enough to be interested in
you know being part of the business from
its birth so we always
knowing that we didn't want a kind of
lifestyle business and the plan was
always to really scale the company we
wanted to to get off to a start where we
could all always deliver from from day
one so how would you describe the first
year then
uh exciting i think obviously we were
working across two different locations
and i think that
may be
only even in the last six twelve months
we've realized what kind of complexity
that brings you're talking about
yeah so obviously ollie's based out of
brighton myself and simon in london and
i think that you can it's quite easy to
fall into the trap of almost running two
separate businesses absolutely um and
it's taken us a long
obviously we've always worked cohesively
we've got really good relationships it's
good good collaboration across the
business
but creating that one kind of unified
company with the same processes the same
go to market
has taken time
yeah yeah i can imagine so
what i'm really interested in then just
i guess you can talk about it may have
changed but like
how how have you ensured all three of
you have like remained
looking at the same north star or have
this the same vision out of interest has
there been challenges with that
you know i mean you're talking about
brian in london
straight away yeah
how have you made sure that you are sort
of locked into
we're all in this together this is where
we want to go out of interest i think
we've always had we've always you know
from
all three of us have always had the same
vision i think that's really helped um
plus we've worked together for 10 years
right
yeah as much a marriage as it is of
business
and i think that from a from a trio we
complement each other really well um we
each have our strengths we each have our
weaknesses we don't actually identify
those strengths and weaknesses until
time right time is i think well you know
over time you really realize what those
are exactly yeah yeah yeah i think it's
taken us years to actually find out
who's what lane
you need to be in what lane we fit in
and
yeah that's kind of a constant process
as well and kind of you know that's
that's still an evolution for me because
you know the business is obviously we've
grown to 17 we want to grow way beyond
that in the next four years
so everyone's got to go through growth
to get there but at the same time also
play to your strengths which is
like you're having to develop new skills
but also then reassess where your
strengths are and where you're where
someone else is strong and they should
be in that way so you've got the benefit
of hindsight like advice for people
now that i think i would most solo
founders i speak to
when i say oh like anything that you
maybe would do differently they'd like
the idea of starting something with
someone else or other people because
obviously it can be imagine if you just
did this on your own there's no signs no
pat et cetera right yeah i'm sure you
think that'd be so hard yeah completely
so like i think can be a really lonely
place exactly yeah so i guess with that
hindsight advice for people that
may i don't know is it maybe good
questions they can ask each other to
find out where their strengths are i
don't know how what advice would you
give people that could enable them to
work out what lane their co-founders
should be and yeah earlier maybe
i think i think it's kind of breaking it
down into the pillars of what a
successful business needs to look like
right you need
you know you need strong business
development skills yeah you need strong
i suppose resourcing skills
you then need good training skills you
need good
entrepreneurial skills in understanding
how the back end of a business needs to
work you've then got contractual
elements that will always come in play
and so i think really understanding what
those pillars are be true to yourself
around where your strengths are and then
potentially look at identifying people
that you know
may have those easier said than done not
sure i think we've been really lucky
that you know we each you know it's
we've complimented each other in that
way um
yeah
and some of that's almost accidental to
be 100
transparent because
you don't realize that you are going to
complement each other really until you
get into that situation right even
though we've worked together a long time
it is a different thing to then go and
fully own a business and you know start
to operate different parts or pillars of
that business as well they said
so it is like
yeah constant discovery process
i think there is also um the natural
tendency to maybe try and
pair up with someone that's like you
yeah absolutely and i think that's
probably the biggest mistake you can
make
i think you know
we look a lot of things like this theory
and stuff and look at personality types
and stuff it's quite interesting but i i
think finding someone that's you know
you know proactive someone that's more
detail-oriented if you look at the
personality blend
um you know even though that can be
frustrating
that someone really wants to move fast
and someone wants to move slow yeah
sometimes if you move too fast and
you're just um task orientated and
results orientated having someone to
rein you in and say actually yeah let's
look at the detail let's look at the
process and slow you down so actually
what you think you need
might actually be completely different
to what you really need and actually if
you look at us as a three we're so
different
but yet because our values are aligned
because our work ethics are aligned
because our standards
everything we talk about is about
standards
and i think because of that because
we're very different
we find a way to work things out and
we're always just take it and go take it
and go and just learn constant learning
i think that's a really good point i
think that's maybe it's part of a
different question but that's really
important from a hiring perspective as
well and creating that blend within the
team you know the people who are
not just the kind of recruitment
almost cliche of like super money
motivated driven obviously those are
important things to have in your team
but you also need someone with an eye
for detail someone who's a bit of a
visionary someone with ideas you know
someone who's a bit more of the glue
between the people
yeah i think the the same things you
need for a business partnership you do
need in kind of you know the teams
you're hiring the teams you're skating
yeah i'm sure you've met other agency
leaders where
it's so easy to like you to hire what's
like you or like some of the people
right yeah i guess um just just to get a
bit of a final bit on the early one day
just just curious for um
people who might be early on their
agency journey like obviously you pat
you said you knew that you didn't want
us to be a lifestyle business so yeah
you would have shared that is it is did
you self-fund the business like how what
what would you think in terms of like do
you like right let's give ourselves a
six month runway we're gonna have to
think about financial doing deals
because obviously you hired people right
away what did that look like
it was task wasn't it helped fund that
exactly
so obviously time acquisition is a
service is enough it's an upfront fee
right so they pay your time and we were
really lucky that we were able to block
out a six-month contract
um so that massively have a question
like massively um
but then i'm of the opinion of
do you know what if
if you've got the right attributes to
step out and do it
then you're gonna make it work the more
pressure you've got on yourself
externally to make it work the more
likely it is to work
comfortable you set yourself up yeah
and the more sort of cushion that you've
got you've got something to fall back on
i guess it's about being like smart and
not totally and i think this is this
goes back to the disc theory you know
i'm very red
which is um if you haven't read it it's
worth reading um
which is you know what just get involved
and so so yes i think yeah the the
not having necessarily lows behind you i
don't see is it
shouldn't necessarily stop something
from going to doing it
depending that you're the right
characteristic yeah right um but at the
same time yeah if you you know think
about it sensibly you know there are
always costs that come up um
and there's always other people looking
for you to fail as well and so with that
in mind you've got to understand that
there's going to be
unforeseen costs that are going to come
your way and people will work against
you wanting to succeed yeah um
so that is quite nicely then let's talk
about a task then for a second so as
that was a big driver as to taking that
leap doing things differently
so what what just talk to us about i
guess like what obviously i'm sure you
agree with quite a few agencies have
some sort of like talent partnership
model it's like a subscription mod or
whatever it is but like what
how did that how was that received
initially from the clients you were
speaking to
like what were you trying to achieve
with it like what were the maybe
different problems you're trying to
solve that maybe typical agency
recruitment may not solve the biggest
challenge of selling a talent
acquisition as a service solution yeah
is
that it sounds too good to be true okay
right so basically what you're doing is
you you're comparing talent acquisition
as a service across the different blends
of recruitment services that you offer
right so you compare it to
a standard recruitment contingent or
retained either way um
and you're comparing it to it to that
solution so fundamentally you're doing
it for a lot cheaper and you're
guaranteeing results so we were
guaranteeing
a certain number of hires over a period
of time okay for her x subscription
exactly so it's kind of like you're
willing to cut your costs in half
theoretically if you produce the the
success that you're talking about um why
are you doing that yeah right and for us
it was long-term relationships
what's the catch what's the catch it
sounds too good to be true and to be
honest with you we set ourselves up for
failure okay because
by
us initially and obviously this was
again and you know it had a big impact
on us as a business um because what we
were willing to do is ensure that we
were um i suppose you know
giving them everything
but forgetting the for a talent
acquisition as a service and this type
of business model to work
both parties have to have to go both
parties have to come to the table and
say right this is what i'm willing to do
but you've got to meet me in the middle
this is why i'm expecting you yeah no
relationship works if it's
by itself sure right yeah that's great
and actually that's why we created white
papers like the trinity search
methodology which is a process which
looks at
things like what is the utopian best
practice for
you know clients being able to to
streamline their recruitment process and
part of that was in order for us to be
able to service our clients they need to
get their house in order right it's not
just about
we're providing them it's also about
helping them so we became again quite
consultative in really helping our
clients understand these are the
bottlenecks that are slowing your
process down yeah help them help us
so yeah so and what it was born out of
going back to
where we started at the beginning of
this in terms of talent acquisition
not just being a usp but like genuinely
solving an industry challenge where
internal t8 isn't working against agency
you know it's an actual partnership
right
getting away from the transactional
being closer to the business
understanding as simon was saying before
about those business drivers and as an
agency aligning to those rather than
just looking at your own motives or your
own
um you know desire to just make
placements there so i think the benefits
of tas in terms of being a genuine usp
solving the transactional relationship
between ta and agency
um can also be its biggest issue because
you're also
assuming that the client is going to
work to your process and a lot of the
time it is a lot of kind of
re-education around the client's process
because you're committing a lot in terms
of your candidates sorry our
consultant's time being aligned to that
business and if their internal processes
is not as good as you think
then tasks can become quite difficult to
work yeah so why don't we so keen so
keen to like segue to like where your
sort of services and solutions what they
look like now because clearly this is a
learning period so i guess
let's just talk a bit about like what
what were some of the key learnings then
so that six month period had that
recurring revenue really trying to focus
on the that problem you're trying to
solve like what were some of the the
loans that you took from that experience
early on
so i think it comes back to a strategy
which has always served us well which is
we've always tried to
align to the business objectives and so
i think tasks
we thought was the answer right but
actually we were selling on on money
yeah and actually what we've tried to do
since is to really really understand the
drivers really understand the business
objectives the business strategy
and anything that we do from a
recruitment perspective we ask
about the strategy of the business and
we see recruitment as an enablement of a
business outcome yeah and so
the everything that we do as a business
res it really kind of is kind of boring
it manifests from that mindset
from our training from our development
from the way we engage with our clients
with our candidates all around that so i
think what's happened since then is
because we've always had that mindset
even though tas
isn't
our our flagship service anymore what we
are able to do is still win those big
retained projects we are still able to
go and win global projects you know with
some of the best clients in the world
because
we understand the challenges we
understand the pains and we attach
ourselves to that whereas before we were
just setting on features and money
yeah and and i think that you'll instead
of playing one fee each time as players
each month like you focus more on that
rather than what you're talking about
and i think it was assuming that the
client's driver was budgeted
yeah yeah and
for some clients it can be you know a
lot of clients do base it on a
recruitment spend but
others are looking for something
completely different and if you go in
you know to any sales process not
understanding what the business drivers
are or what the value is to that
customer
then
you you can go wrong basically we took
it at face value because the common
concern or the the objective of setting
up a talent
acquisition function within a business
is to reduce agency dependency and
reduce agency cost so we thought okay
let's just attach ourselves to cost
whereas there was so much more there was
so much more than just it being a cost
implication um
so we then help build that out um
so yeah it was it was an interesting
journey and you know as a business
obviously we still do it but it's you
know so it's not maybe not like the
flagship when maybe when you started it
you thought that would have been the
flagship but you know the learnings and
stuff it's evolved yeah we feel like
we've got different weapons that we can
use for different scenarios and i think
our journey of sales is really
understand the business and really
understand why why why you know ask
those why questions understand those
situation questions and also attach
ourselves to the personal win of who
we're selling to because a lot of the
time the reason why they're taking you
down a direction or they're blocking you
is because you you're misaligned so if
we can really understand that we can
sell retained if that's time we turn
retain work away
you know it retainers and everything we
turn it away if
the outcome is not going to be worth the
effort so it's about understanding the
drivers and then tailoring the right
solution tasks could be the perfect
solution if they've got the right
processes so we can be a lot more
objective
and much more tactical
with our approach and bespoke by just
listening and investing that time with
the client
so what i'm keen to go into now then
i'll
that's what i've always admired about
you guys like the way that you think
like she's completely it is different i
know it's like cliche differently but i
think as you said you're trying to get
away from just the recruitment talk and
really understand what they're trying to
achieve and why and then understand if
you can enable that by getting them the
right people or giving them the right
advice and those things so
how does this the way that you're
talking about things how does this
manifest then in terms of like the types
of people that you guys hire or the
types of people that you look for
because and the way that you train them
and develop them because i think
it isn't going to be like that so there
are the typical cliche just like only in
it for them and wants to just make that
deal or not think do you get what i mean
so i'm sure you've been on the journey
of that in the last
two years three years alone like how is
that
i think it's probably the most ironic
thing isn't it a recruitment company is
really struggling with typically yeah
yeah number one challenge
yes i think that's common in the
industry
yeah um
i think the biggest thing we've got away
from is looking at experience or just
looking for
you know certain client connections or
even market knowledge i think so the
biggest switch
that we've made is looking for really
specific characteristics within people
um some sales experience is great but
apart from that is intelligence
character and coachability intelligence
character and coachability yeah
yeah so we know that with the training
development program which can simon can
give a bit more detail about the
playbook side
if we find those people with the right
characteristics and you know some of
those cliches are still important right
you know hunger drive competitiveness
are still
things that can make you successful in
sales but
it's not about you know having 18 months
experience in recruitment for us it's
about
how driven you are to learn not just our
methodologies but really like
continuously learn and develop and
become a master in your market a lot of
that was born through our clients so
we're working with some of the well most
exciting hybrid software companies in
the world
and you know they they turn cds upside
down they look at attributes before they
look at experience and that was kind of
a bit of a eureka moment for us when we
kind of thought okay
hold on a minute that should be how we
is that how we should be thinking about
recruitment and and that's what we
changed our sort of tact
and how long has how long when did do
you think that really you really like
committing to that because i'm sure that
along the way you've maybe been a bit
lenient with it at times and you've been
like
if the podcast was there the podcast bit
that was the real kind of wow um that's
then also then calling um
which we talk about in a bit you know
when we talk about non-exec directors
and influence and people coming in the
influence from our side is influenced
from the people in our industry they're
scaling software companies they're
scaling sales organizations
and so a lot of our kind of inspiration
has has really come from them the the
the challenge um was how do we go and
qualify those actions
right it's not necessarily about exactly
how do we then but again
the individuals that we are working with
have mastered this right they they
understand how to qualify individuals
around intelligence right i think when
you look at intelligence and it's in
itself people are thinking okay you know
academic academic academic now academic
is not necessarily
the only thing of intelligence right got
book smart we've also got street smart
people i definitely wouldn't class
myself as an academic as such
um but at the same time i'm pretty
street smart you know i can see
opportunities and i look at things um
not in necessarily a linear fashion yeah
looking at very
objective the characteristics are you
know
give me give me examples of you know
where you've challenged you've been
challenged you've dealt with adversity
in your life right not necessarily just
in work but you know what have you
overcome when you've been pushed up
against the wall how have you managed to
you know fight back
um then the coachability is simple right
people have got to be willing to learn
and people got to be willing to take on
new ideas
um
and so yeah so the intelligence
characteristics and coachability piece
is really interesting but i think if you
look at all the software companies that
we recruit for um jeremy duggan being a
big influence in there people like john
mcmahon um you know jeremy duggan
himself has actually called it ice
criteria which is the intelligence
characteristics coach of between
so it's an actual terminology used in
the industries yeah
so
to go back to your question as well i
think
it took us about two two and a half
years to get to that point okay and so
it's really last 12 18 months and i
would say even the last
six months has still seen another leap
in identifying those characteristics
it's easy to fall into the habit of just
hiring people you like
yeah you want to like them and see those
attributes and values for your business
as well yeah because i think that's i've
definitely also known you guys for a
little while i do feel like
since we last spoke and stuff i feel
like if things have just gone up a notch
and stuff and that's what i was
interested in it seems like a big part
of it is
like what you're talking about like just
being really committed to like what you
want to build and staying true to that
um
so obviously
you're talking about getting better
identifying those things in the
interview process
how how does it manifest then when we're
measuring performance does that change
anything i've interested do you look at
anything different in terms of measuring
those characteristics we're continuing
to see yeah is there anything different
maybe that you look at that might be
away from the typical
performance metrics that recruitment
agency leaders look at yeah absolutely
so i think we were guilty of really just
judging people on on results even if we
didn't want to i think everything was
results if you if you're performing then
that's fine and i think that's probably
the biggest transformation in our
business is that
that's not all right just because you're
doing you're doing well so what we're
looking for is people that genuinely um
dedicated to their continuous learning
i think that it's very natural that you
know as a recruiter once you leave reach
a certain level of competence
you become you you enter a comfort zone
where you're kind of just yeah you get
really complacent with where you are and
i think that within this business what
we're trying to do is make sure that
people are continuously
we we have to inspire them as to why
they should better themselves give them
the tools that they need to better
themselves but we we
have to constantly push that now the
reason i say that because when when we
measure success and for promotions
within our business it's not just
revenue we're also tracking mastery so
we've got playbooks that we're rolling
out specifically looking at different
areas of what we do and it's all around
the best practice it's all about you
know that whole elevating yourself above
the noise and that whole advisory
service and everything that we do and so
we're constantly pushing our consultants
to reach mastery so even if they're
hitting revenue targets
we still we we show them the potential
imagine if you were able to
master this more if you were able to
squeeze that little bit more what what
what that can mean for you so and this
is also ties into the attributes if
you've got the wrong attributes you're
not going to buy into that that's why
the coachability that's why the
intelligence that's why the horsepower
needs to be there so it all ties
together i think
again looking at it from a results
perspective
i think particularly the last six to 12
months we're less focused on outcomes
because we know if the characteristics
as we've said but also the inputs are
there the attitudes there
you know they're working to a
consistently really high standard across
everything then they're going to build
way above the industry average you know
we've had people billing 25 30k on
average per month consistently and and
way above that but it's almost taking it
away from x amount of money per month
and looking at breaking it down into
every little element of what people are
doing to enable them to
you know really master their market and
perfect the art of head hunting in the
tech space so how so i obviously i speak
to a lot of valencia leaders around
learning development i think most agency
leaders will tell you that they want
those types of people in their business
like they want to develop and those
types of things but how
how how does this actually look like in
practice in terms of like is it every
week
at a certain time everyone's doing
training development like how is it
really important onboarding process so
from day one when i'm work for soap i
know training is important how does it
actually yeah i mean how does it show up
in actual
practice like how have you gone about
ingrained because i feel like the size
you're at now it's so important to
really have those and then when you grow
it's just part of the fabric of soap
right so how are you ingraining it in
practice out of interest so there's two
things obviously there's the initial
training and
three days before they even learn
anything technical
is about understanding the values
and the importance of that dedication to
mastery and it's really spending three
days is just aligning to the
the values of the business it sounds
remarkable in a dark room with simon
but in that time we're literally talking
about what are the things that are
important to you you know where are you
going in your career why are you here
you know what does it take to be world
class why do athletes master you know
what's the difference between a
world-class athlete if you're gonna be
here be the best you can be
so how can we do that so that's that's
where it starts so
the mindset needs to come before
anything
so
if we get the mindset right
that's when we can get to work and if
the mindset's not there there is no work
to be done but once we're in
it's three weeks intense learning curve
like you wouldn't believe but they come
out of it
and
they sound this is not experienced
recruiters they sound like
seasoned seasoned advisors you know and
and and that's a consequence of you know
the playbook and hiring the right people
and the training and lots of other
things which is a in progress
but then
continuous after that
every week they have mastery milestones
that they need to meet especially for
the first kind of um
three to six months
and then it's constantly every week
there's listening to calls we've got the
crib sheets so we in our playbook we've
we've literally mapped out um standards
across what exceptional looks like so
everyone now can sit down together
listen to a call
and they've got exactly the same
perspective of what exception or what's
good
what
of those standards so there's no
it's no longer subjective everyone knows
what the standards are
i think it's really important as well
that training is not just
something you need in your business and
then it's you know management passes
someone over to the trainer because
they're weak in one area i think it has
to be an actual core pillar of the
business so as well as the management
side as well as the business development
side you've also got continuous training
development and that is bred into people
from day one because then as you scale
the company
that same dedication to that is always
there yeah
how i'm just curious
um one of the biggest challenges i
always hear from recruiters earlier on
their journey is that luck is like the
lack of self belief or that feel like
that lack of credibility early on mm-hmm
do you experience how do you have the
microphone that have been dressed oh
they said they go like yeah
you know
the most scripted thing in the world
perfect words that you've spent two days
writing if you don't believe what you're
saying
neither will the candidate yeah
there was an epiphany moment i remember
we sat on a on a candidate on a
a call so as a whole company we sit
together and we listen to a call
together we all analyze it so the whole
company together an hour right and we're
on that and we were talking about you
know i don't believe you i don't believe
you
and there was a bit of a penny drop
moment which was belief system okay so
actually part of the playbook
is
if you believe the things that you're
saying and you see yourself above the
noise we talk about above the noise so
really elevating yourself if you see
yourself above the noise you will find
the words to communicate that belief
yeah so i can give you the script can
teach you everything you need to know
but if you don't believe it
it's always going to you're always going
to communicate from how you see yourself
if you've got limited beliefs of
yourself that's always when you're going
to be anti-selling so to really help
you know people break that and
communicate in that right way we need to
give them those perspectives and the
whole playbook is built on the
psychology of selling
so things like you know tonality and you
know how you influence people but also
the belief system is people attach
themselves to the emotion and justify
with logic
and so you know creating that
opportunity for people to attach
themselves to that emotion
is the hope it's through the belief yeah
so that's yeah a lot of leadership
training focuses on building influences
right and people who can obviously talk
about the value they can give to you and
and
and then why you should follow those
people
and i think especially in our market and
a lot of other
headhunt markets you're asking people
you know maybe mid 20s late 20s you know
a lot of time in our case
to have a belief system as that they can
go and influence very senior people very
quickly
so you almost built needing obviously
you're training recruitment but you're
training those kind of influencer and
leadership skills even though they're
not directly managing
they have to believe that they have
the value to influence people yeah now i
just love that because i i've recorded a
recent series which is like early on in
a recruitment and one of the biggest
challenges that i have to work for is
that self-belief that self-confidence so
the fact you're trying to like really
support and attack that from their door
is just going to mean that they're going
to have an even better chance of being
successful and build on that so
so let's just before before we finish
let's just segue to where this business
is going then because i know that
you're all of you guys are really
excited as to where it's going so talk
to me a bit about
i guess one how your view in the next
six to 12 months
also just talk to me a bit about
what have been some of the maybe recent
investments that you may have been being
people or certainly looking to make that
you feel is really going to enable you
guys to
achieve that vision that you're yeah i i
suppose i'd like to focus on the last
question which is you know i suppose
where we're investing our time so we're
investing our time a lot within our in
our business service department um
and a lot one of the biggest areas of
that is on
video production and marketing okay um
now we're not looking at traditional
marketing solutions you know building
our brand we're looking
to be honest it was inspired by you
came to us right which is um
that process that you went through in
helping us build our own brands
really sets off on a journey it sets
them on a journey you know
not only is it what we want to be as a
brand
but we believe our business is made up
of the people within our business and we
truly believe that and so
we went on a personal discovery session
with you which is you know what what who
do you want to be what do you want to do
which then led us into
our podcast series hunters and unicorns
and a really successful series of 33
cxos yes that is the plug
but it's um it was a real interesting
journey and i think
you know i think it's a really really
important thing that we're really now
supporting people whoever joins our
business in that ability to be able to
help them go through that same journey
that you helped us go through um and
with the hunters and unicorns platform
itself
um and with
an actual team of developers um
videotographers
we're actually able to put together
really professional um you know i
suppose
marketing material and
supporting document for individuals
joining our business right yeah um
okay
business services
yeah well business services is more it's
quite a well-rounded function so
actually business services enables
everything to really prop up
so you talk about the challenges of
managers not really you know being
spread too thin conventionally and
recruitment business services you know
takes a lot of that burden away to be
able to elevate people so business
services takes care of training it it
takes care of you know a lot of the
processes which take a lot of time you
know marketing development recruitment
enablement a lot of the operational
functions which you take for granted a
business our size is investing so
heavily in that
which is quite unique and that's because
we are scaling you know we're building
the foundations of a scalable business
um because we don't want to retrofit
that we want to bake that in from day
one so business services is a huge huge
play
personal development plans for every
single person in this business
you know mentoring programs management
frameworks all of these things that all
of these processes are really kind of
baked into that business service
function
i think it's because we've also got
necessarily a complex business model
we're trying to steer away from
um
being manager the only way to be able to
progress in a business is by going into
a management position you know we'd be
as a high performer
not necessarily the highest performing
sales individuals are going to be the
best managers right um and so
to enable
um everybody with an opportunity to have
some form of career progression get to
director associate director you know
directorship board level everybody needs
some sort of plan which again goes back
to what we're talking about the
beginning is understanding your lanes
right i might be a really good business
development person and i love doing that
right but that's all i love doing okay
well we've got a lame for you here
if you want to
become you know you just love the
candidate sourcing part you just you
know that's that's what you really focus
on you become a director in this
business and do nothing more
and so
as i said but in order to be able to
create that framework in a management
sorry to create that you need the
complexity of having a business service
around you to support those functions
it's going back to the characteristics
piece um and hiring
you know
everyone wants intelligent character
good characteristics and coachability
right but those are very high potential
people naturally so
what kind of platform or what kind of
business or environment do they need to
be in and i think you know
by creating by trying to create the
platform that we are to to then scale it
we need to give the people
right now at ground level and associate
level with no prior recruiting
experience the opportunity to grow into
those senior roles rather than bringing
in experience managers over the top of
them it's about identifying not just
that they're good recruiters but yeah
this person has great characteristics to
be a future leader and how do you then
develop that person so
rather than
you know
bringing in just senior experienced
people and bringing in
inexperience under them really give
those opportunity
give those people the opportunity to
grow through the ranks
yeah that is like the most common driver
i hear from young people it is
progression that that's what they want
so
i love that so look let's um
let's wrap this up then so i guess what
i just love to hear from all of you
is really like where what what's the
i guess ultimate
goal vision ambition for soap then we
can finish it there like what how do you
see this business another four years
what what does the future look like
well in one line we want to be the
number one technology recruitment
business globally yeah sales to laundry
sales
go to market practice yeah
okay
there's a basic overview yeah i i think
we want to see ourselves as the
one of the best
training and development recruitment
companies in the world and i think
there's no shying against that we want
to hire extremely high potential people
give them a platform where they really
feel inspired and enabled elevate their
belief system to a level that they
perhaps didn't even realize they could
achieve and just really you know create
an environment where people can feel
part of something quite special
it sounds a bit generic but actually
genuinely we are dedicated to that and
we come to work every single day
to work for that and i think that's
that's the common vision that all three
of us and everyone in this business is
all working towards i don't know mm-hmm
yeah i think furthering you know
personal development is is part of it
but also giving you know individuals the
platforms and you know on the back of
the podcasts you know and helping people
create their whys you know create their
um their brand their brand you know
establish themselves you know
i think that in today's market you know
businesses and recruitment companies are
likely to shy away from doing that
because at the end of the day they're
helping that personal brand rather than
the company brand which you know
inevitably could lead on to
um you know the individuals going off
and you know starting up themselves you
know i think that then then becomes the
retention part how do i look at
retaining those individuals so don't go
off and do that um and i'd rather deal
with that challenge
rather than the
suppressor don't invest
suppressing somebody and not allowing
somebody to grow and and get better and
you know for me as i said you know i
still absolutely love the recruitment
part and you know i think some of the
people that we've got in the business
you know i just look at i think you know
what
not only did you show high potential
what you're now doing is fast you know
surpassing anything that i could have
ever achieved in recruitment and to see
that you know that for me is just
you know it's fantastic
that's obviously what makes
going and all of your own business
journey are special isn't it like
exactly what all you guys get so excited
about is seeing these other people what
you can build to help these people
maximize their potential yeah that's
just obviously the great thing so look
after your stuff they're gonna look
after you that's it well um it's been a
pleasure excites you where you guys are
in another four years but thanks a lot
for coming on the pod thanks for joining
us cheers
[Music]